y es hora de hablar de economía aquí en
directo América en France 24 por ello me
acompaña en el estudio mi compañero
Jorge Hurtado Jorge bienvenido vamos a
iniciar el Líbano donde los bancos han
tenido que cerrar por temores de
seguridad y es que en la última semana
Valentina O al menos 7 asaltos a
entidades bancarias y no de ladrones
comunes sino más bien de ciudadanos que
están molestos porque los bancos no Les
regresan sus ahorros por esto los bancos
decidieron cerrar sus puertas desde este
lunes por al menos tres días pero el
cierre simbólico porque realmente los
bancos no tienen suficientes Divisas
para quienes ahorraron y ahora piden su
dinero de regreso pero el banco les
congeló las cuentas o perdieron mucho
valor la crisis económica y se agudizó
en 2019 con una pobreza que afecta más
del 80% de la población que ha visto
perder alrededor del 95% del valor de la
libra libanesa que es la moneda local
que alcanzó nuevos mínimos este lunes
llegó a cotiza a 38.600 libras por dólar
hubo manifestaciones también el Palacio
de justicia de beirut por la detención
de dos personas implicadas en los
asaltos bancarios la población los ve
como una especie de Héroes que reclaman
sus derechos la crisis financiera
ampliamente atribuida a la corrupción y
a la mala gestión del gobierno provocó
la peor crisis económica de la historia
del Líbano según Naciones Unidas 4 de
cada cinco libaneses viven en la pobreza
Jorge hay una crisis que parece no tener
solución a corto plazo bueno el banco de
pagos internacionales recomendó subir
los tipos de interés pese a un mayor
riesgo de recesión el banco presentó su
informe trimestral de septiembre
aclarando que si había riesgo de
recesión este ha aumentado la
institución afirma que los países más
vulnerables a los precios de la energía
son los que más riesgo tienen de sufrir
una recesión económica el informe
analiza la situación económica global y
los movimientos de los mercados desde
principios de junio y hasta de
septiembre desde agosto cientos de
inversores anticipan una inflación más
alta producto de los problemas de
abastecimiento energético en Europa y
porque el mercado laboral en Estados
Unidos continúa siendo bastante robusto
podríamos decir que este es el año del
endurecimiento Global en materia
monetaria aquí un ejemplo de ellos si la
reserva Federal de Estados Unidos parece
dispuesta a llevar a esa economía que es
la más grande del mundo una recesión
económica si es necesario para tratar de
controlar o domar la inflación es un
mensaje que otros bancos centrales del
mundo están siguiendo según bloomberg
más de 90 bancos centrales subieron los
tipos de interés este año la mitad lo
hicieron en al menos 75 puntos básicos
de una sola vez según GP Morgan en el
trimestre actual se van a producir Las
mayores subidas de tipos de interés de
los principales bancos centrales desde
el año 1980 esta semana se esperan
subidas en Estados Unidos también se
prevé que el banco de Inglaterra aumente
su índice de re en 50 puntos básicos y
nuevos aumentos en Indonesia Noruega
filipinas Suecia y Suiza una encuesta de
gestores de fondos reveló que las
expectativas de crecimiento mundial
Estaban cerca de sus mínimos históricos
una de las razones Es que la política
monetaria funciona con cierto retraso
primero debilita los mercados
financieros luego la economía y
finalmente el objetivo principal que es
la inflación de modo que la subida de
los tipos de interés de forma agresiva
se vuelven peligrosas para la economía
global se sigue complicando el panorama
económico a nivel global bueno íbamos a
Argentina que cerró la segunda revisión
del acuerdo de refinanciación de deudas
con el fondo monetario internacional
Bueno este acuerdo todavía está sujeto a
la aprobación definitiva por parte del
directorio ejecutivo del fmi y una vez
completada la revisión Argentina tendría
acceso a unos 3.900 millones de dólares
el prestamista dijo que las recientes y
decisivas medidas adoptadas por el
gobierno argentino están contribuyendo
para restaurar la confianza el
presidente argentino Alberto Fernández
mantuvo un encuentro presencial en Nueva
York con la directora gerente del fmi
cristalina y yorlleva Argentina pasó su
presupuesto 2023 donde prevé un
crecimiento del 2% y una inflación del
60% para el próximo año contempla
también el cumplimiento de las
principales metas con el fmi como la
reducción del déficit fiscal al 1,9% del
producto interno bruto Y hasta ahora
según el organismo la acciones decisivas
del nuevo equipo económico están
disipando las presiones del mercado lo
que deja sin cambios las perspectivas de
crecimiento del 4% que se tiene para
este año bueno y finalizamos hablando de
la pandemia y la guerra en Ucrania que
están ejerciendo incluso más presión
sobre los pobres en el mundo así lo
advirtió la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económico
ocde de hecho antes de la guerra 60
estados territorios y localidades
cayeron el año pasado en la categoría de
contexto frágiles lo que significa que
estaban expuestos a riesgos económicos
medioambientales sociales y políticos
los 60 representan el 24% de la
población mundial el 73% de los que
viven en pobreza extrema el 80% de los
que murieron en algún tipo de conflicto
y la gran mayoría de los focos de hambre
del mundo según este organismo los cinco
países más frágiles el año pasado fueron
somalias o durante el sur Afganistán
yemen y la República centroafricana
Jorge usted Gracias por esta ampliación
económica Seguimos aquí en directo
América con directo
[Música]